boulet kev podcast the freestyle king
little flip the legend is here shout out
lrg clothing and uh
yo this guy first of all we just had a
crazy interview go check it out but
let's get to the rapping man that's what
he came to do he's a legend he's the
freestyle king yeah let's start with the
first beat hey let's go
the headphones up a little bit
the beat yeah yeah
exactly pop in my cup okay cut the beat
up just a little bit
yeah
everywhere i got a double cup
y'all drinking fake [ __ ] bubble guts
i might hit you with a uppercut
plate say kiss my ass hook her up
i ain't fell off i'm still in this [ __ ]
she want to be friends with benefits
i need the cash what's your credit score
i'm a king treat me like that are you
ready fo
taking trips while we walk into the vip
they give me bottles and i ain't even
pressed to [ __ ] no model
i just need a hundred grand for an hour
i just made 100 grand while in the
shower
bootleg my cds i don't even care a lot
of rappers get cash and ain't even
shared scramble in the pocket andre wear
imma get cash gray hair old money samuel
l jackson i got that million dollar
videos in two days i shot day yeah
leopard cats where your spot said yeah
extend those where your glock said you
got shot and never shot back okay you
are ain't no gangsters and i saw that
look i was in memphis with all the real
killers i went to pittsburgh i wasn't
with no stillers but [ __ ] on the field
they saying hut one hut two cup one cut
two and i still hold it down for screw
all right peter pimp c he had his own
style [ __ ] i'm 400 degrees like i'm
juvenile now i'm warmed up let me put my
blunt down uh playing duck hunt let me
put my pump down uh
i'm the type to hit the club and go to
the front i'm the type to put a lot of
wax in my blunt shot out the weed
perfect he can roll some other [ __ ] just
like a origin you better find out who
you [ __ ] with gorilla flowing on
gloria i'm getting cash a lot of rappers
ain't got no skriller i went to mobile
yeah alabama
last week i was chilling with david
banner we did a new record for my movie
soundtrack i got gray i got gold and i
got brown plaques
let's keep it going okay switch it up a
little yeah i can spit some
yeah deep [ __ ] on this [ __ ] like
shout out to benny the butcher man
huh
and drums kind of remind me
[Music]
to be a spitter
you gotta have punch lines like killer
kylian that's my partner see i'm a m.c i
can rap the basic flower i can hit you
with some [ __ ] that's vicious like cool
joe all i need is one mic like my name
gnaws i came from cloverland grew up
under the botany boys i bounced up
rings plush [ __ ] that [ __ ] i king duck
i got the crown and it's sitting lit
look
pulled up in the double law remember
days i made that coke bubble hard i was
on the block had a knot full of rocks
and i seen the [ __ ] cops and they got
raided by the swats i wasn't about to go
through that [ __ ] so i went out of
town with some brown and a full clip
yeah i'm gonna take over gator gamer
makeover
a lot of cats they walk around with fake
clothes i'm the original they throw
subliminal shots i'm h time dog this a
criminal plot watch the movie don't miss
the [ __ ] that i'm gonna do
h time baby we still bang screw i hit
the turkey leg hood they got what i like
to eat then i went down the street shop
that active at the lead i spent a wreck
went to my hood and checked on my
properties i played monopoly my game is
triopoly exotic billion dollar company
they thought we fell off they were still
wishing my well off you must don't know
how many elbows i mail y'all my plug and
cali my [ __ ] i can't tell y'all still
up in this [ __ ] let this [ __ ]
break down and it's freestyle it's like
a chucklerdale down tap out [ __ ] i pull
a mac out [ __ ] oh you louse down low
ways to put your map out [ __ ] when i
back out [ __ ] i'm on the back block
[ __ ] i was a have not the leprechaun by
the jackpot [ __ ] i watch matlock [ __ ]
up in my crack spot [ __ ] i spent 200k
for cameras in my trap spot [ __ ] a real
street [ __ ] shoot you get it back to
him and [ __ ] that's the fleet flicker
cos amigos i like that but not cheap
liquor won't catch me drinking no no
tito's but i ain't from eight to year
but roll with my amigos mama i miss my
mama mary watching old shows when harry
met sally
when i went to seattle i had a whole
boat i'm from h-town down there we blow
dro went to tennessee i mean i went to
tennessee because my o.g he said he
still got it for tennerkey yeah free bg
big meech and larry hoover tatted on my
right leg chucky and freddy krueger yeah
i'm chatting up i got some mo i gotta
get yo freestyle king i just screwed up
click put my cds out and then i blew up
quick and if she say she in the red and
[ __ ] come to some [ __ ] i'm like a pimp
mode i went to papadose they call me
flip weather i could hit you with some
body blows since i was a snotty nose all
my albums they platinum but when i'm
riding around trapping [ __ ] my shotty
gold i got my apron on like benny the
butcher they about to get pumped where's
ashton kutcher yeah i get the cash and
then i dip out i do a show when i come
in i bring the bloods in the crib side
i'm the boss in this spanish el haifey
i'm from houston we get our work from
the essays el hino i'm a genius got
[ __ ] playing tennis
like venus and sabrina effortless
effortless ladies and gentlemen yeah
freestyle king
go run up all the new music uh you say
you just dropped a new video yeah me and
zero um it's called own tonight check
that [ __ ] out
kings of the south two coming out of
freestyle three of the beyond august
19th
and we just working smart man king light
movie is on the way
me and david bennett got some new music
so much happening man it's it's crazy
man stay oh yeah but make sure you
support easy to block captain album we
got a joint venture we did a deal you
know he's on king like family in three
faces so
timothy is out and reid dollar's album
is coming out he's a club with g so you
know i [ __ ] with the battle rap tough
yeah yeah yeah so i'm bringing my league
back yeah
that rap is a
it's it's it's his own culture man yeah
i love it man there it is
that was fire as [ __ ] hey i know you
just watched a brand new freestyle
presented to you by our good folks at
lrg don't forget if you go to lrg right
now the website will be right there
broom l dash r dash g dot com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
get thirty percent off your order that's
l dash r dash g dot com you'll see it
right down there
save 30 off your order by putting in
that promo code bootleg and shout out to
lrg we got another freestyle coming next
week